the temperature often dips two- double
digits in a Meccano russia long known as
the coldest inhabited place on earth
it's so cold that people here consume
frozen meat keep their cars running 24/7
and must warm the ground with bonfires
for several days before burying their
dead it's the kind of place
photographer amos Chappell could not
resist she travelled more than ten
thousand miles to reach this village of
500 residents tucked away in a remote
corner of Siberia it took two days to
arrive by car from Yukos the nearest
major city which is 576 miles away
Chapel spent several weeks shooting a
Naima cone and Yakutsk during the long
dark month of January in 2013 and 14 his
remarkable photos captured the cold
bleak landscape and the hardy residents
who brave unimaginable conditions i'muh
consists just a few hundred miles away
from the Arctic Circle it's dark for up
to 21 hours a day during the winter and
the temperature averages minus 58 that's
balmy compared to 1 February in 1933
when I makan earned his title as the
coldest place on earth when the mercury
plunged to minus 90 here artichoke is
simply a fact of life
most people use outhouses because indoor
plumbing tends to freeze cars are kept
in heated garages or if left outside
left running all the time nothing edible
grows in the frozen ground
so people are primarily carnivorous
trouble faced unending challenges while
shooting he had to hold his breath while
snap
as the steam from his mouth would swirl
around like cigar smoke he wandered
around with his jacket half opened
trying to keep the camera warm against
his body and drawing it out only when he
had a shot